so rest easy ladies and gentlemen a
special counsel is supposedly looking
into Joe Biden they haven't produced
anything that we know of so the Daily
Mail has to fill the Gap they just found
proof that Biden's brother Jimmy fast
Jimmy Biden was hired by a construction
company to negotiate with the Saudi
government while Joe Biden was vice
president because he's an expert
on Middle East construction we're also
learning at the University of Delaware
like the University of Pennsylvania made
a ton of money from can you guess oh yes
China after Joe Biden opened a fake
Institute there the dumbest man in
politics as an academic Institute a
source tells Fox News that the FBI
recently searched the University of
Delaware twice for classified documents
belonging to Biden the FBI is still
assessing whether there were any
classified documents there Peter
Schweitzer is probably the most talented
digger
into information like this in the United
States he's president of the government
accountability Institute and we're
really happy to join us tonight Peter
thank you for coming on what do you make
of this what does it mean
uh it's very important I mean look
Tucker if you look at the Nexus of these
Financial ties that the bidens have with
China you have to go back to the Chinese
State and you also have to go back to
Chinese intelligence uh let's keep in
mind Hunter Biden got three big deals in
China some of that money he shared with
James Biden you know potentially it went
to other family members if you look at
all three of the businessmen that made
those deals happen those ties are there
the first one was a guy named Che Fang
he helped set up Hunter Biden on that
bhr private Equity deal that netted
Hunter perhaps 20 million dollars based
on estimates uh when he set Hunter Biden
up with that deal Jay Fang was partners
with a gentleman named maggian who was
the vice Minister for State security in
China with responsible for foreign
recruitment that's from Hong Kong
corporate records the second deal that
was set up for Hunter Biden was a guy
named Henry Zhao Henry Zhao transferred
five billion dollars into 100 Biden's
Accounts at the time he did that Henry
zhao's business partners with the
daughter of the former minister of State
security who ran the entire spy
apparatus of China if you look at
chairman Yi the cefc the Energy company
his previous job was working for Chinese
Military Intelligence so when you're
talking about money coming from China to
the bidens when you're talking about
concerns about classified records when
you're concerned about what did the
bidens actually do in return for that
money these are all very serious
legitimate questions that I don't have
much confidence at all that the
Department of Justice is going to look
into
it just seems so obvious I mean these
dots really do connect and again I have
confidence in no one more than you in in
getting to the bottom of complex money
related stories but is there any doubt
that what looks like was going on was
actually going on
yeah I mean uh Tucker uh you know you
and I uh both went through the Cold War
at least the 1980s imagine if Ronald
Reagan's family or Jimmy Carter's family
took you know tens of millions of
dollars from Russian businessmen linked
to the KGB would there be any question
at all that this requires serious
investigation instead what we're getting
from a lot of people as well you you
can't prove that a crime was being
committed it's an absurd standard needs
to be looked at
Peter Schweitzer great to see you
tonight thank you
thanks subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight